[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je passe mon téléphone à la personne qui
est dommage c'est trop mignon jadot j'ai
pas ce téléphone aux salles 2 et
l'équipe je basse quand elle à celui qui
arrive toujours le dernier sur le
tournage eh oui fais moi elles ont
d'abord je pense compte elle
sert à quoi
[Musique]
alors moi j'étais dans une boîte j'ai vu
que des flics homme qui met des chaunois
darkness bling comme ça mais c'est quoi
ces déclins en europe il se pense qu'en
mettant des faux culs et faire du gros
gibier première kim mais c'est pas ça en
fait il ya un gros problème
d'originalité ans
[Musique]
vasily paraît jeu c'est limité parce
qu'elle est passée par
[Rires]
là je veux dire je suis curieux de
voir
super le croco tu fais le croco pas trop
fait la place se jouera s'est assis
couché oui tu es kruger teklak lac
à boire à bois
oui